[Music]
[Applause]
what you didn't see that i saw was first
of all a body that was not blurred out
a body that was twitching and moving
with every shot that landed as it was on
the ground
the shots continued after he was on the
ground
we saw that it's there
it's real
jalen was shot more times than i can
count
and that is beyond troubling
we are done
dying like this
we do not know the exact number of
rounds that were fired a lot of rounds
were fired
vehicle just had a shot come out of its
door
there's no doubt that the video you just
watched is extremely disturbing and will
stir a lot of emotions and feelings
shocking
[Music]
what i'm here to say
is that we are done dying like this
in this manner
with this fate
nobody
should ever suffer the fate that jalen
walker did
with the amount of shots that were fired
what does that say about
the way police handle situations like
this in america i'm afraid that law
enforcement fights against us
[Music]